[MUSIC]
One of the core findings of our research,
is that the political arguments
that are going to are going to be
effective for building a bigger consensus
in the US is usually an argument
you haven't heard before.
It's an argument that advocates for
a policy or a candidate in terms of
the values and beliefs of the people
that are being targeted for persuasion.
[MUSIC]
We've tested this idea both ways.
We've looked at whether liberal policy
positions do better when they're
framed in terms of conservative values and
we find that they do
because they pull greater support from
conservatives and sometimes moderates.
And we've also looked at whether
conservative policy positions perform
better when they're reframed in
terms of liberal values, and
again, we find that they do.
So for example, if you were to reframe
military spending as consistent with
equality of opportunity and social
justice, making the case for the military
as an institution where the poor and
minorities can achieve on a relatively
level playing field with other Americans,
liberals will be more open to supporting
high levels of military spending after
they hear an argument like that.
[MUSIC]
A few years ago, we got really interested
in same sex marriage attitudes, and we're
interested in whether certain persuasive
techniques might be more effective for
building support for same sex marriage.
And so to explore this idea,
we ran an experiment where we had people
either read a relatively conventional
argument for same sex marriage that said
that gay marriage should be legal because
of the values of equality, fairness,
gay people should have the same
rights as anybody else.
We compared the effects of that
message to a very different message
that made the case for same sex marriage
in terms of the values of patriotism and
group loyalty.
And it said that, gay people are proud,
patriotic Americans,
they serve in the military, they
contribute to our economy and our society.
And for that reason, they deserve
the same rights as anybody else.
And what we found is that that second
message was significantly more persuasive
and it was especially more persuasive
with conservatives who are normally
reluctant to support same sex marriage,
especially at the time we ran
the study a few years ago.
But then when they heard that argument
in terms of their own values,
more conservative values around
patriotism, group loyalty,
they said okay,
like this is starting to speak to me,
and some of them moved their
positions on these issues.
[MUSIC]
Most recently, we ran an experiment on
how to make the most persuasive appeal
you could for an economically
progressive political candidate, and
specifically a presidential candidate.
So we're interested in is there a way
to build greater levels of support for
economically progressive candidates.
And the reason we were interested in
this is that if you look historically,
Americans are actually quite
supportive of federal jobs programs,
minimum wage increases, paid family leave,
these sorts of programs,
they poll very well in America.
But Americans don't necessarily vote for
the candidates that would pass those
policies, and so
they don't get passed at a high rate.
So we're very interested in this puzzle.
So what we did was we
constructed an experiment
where we had a candidate who supported
these pretty popular policies.
And we either had them talk about those
policies in terms of classically liberal
values like equality, social justice,
protecting vulnerable people, or we
had them talk about them in what are often
thought to be more conservative values of
respect for tradition, caring for family,
the American dream, things like that.
And what we found was that candidate, that
second candidate that talked in terms of
more conservative values, but
about economically progressive policies,
was clearly the most popular candidate
in the experiment that we ran.
They gained extra support from
moderates and conservatives alike.
And they were essentially in the study
we ran, a shoo in to win an election.
[MUSIC]
One thing that I think is really
attractive about moral reframing is it
offers an alternative to our only real
technique that we think of now as a way
to build political consensus,
which is compromise.
Compromise on policy,
move to the perceived middle, and
that's going to be the way to pick up
51% of voters or get something passed.
And that's an unsatisfying tool
if it's the only tool you have.
And so it's attractive, I think,
to have another alternative.
Another way that you could add voters,
add people to your
base of support besides just changing
the policy positions you advocate for,
especially if you think those
are the right policy positions.
[MUSIC]
You think about Barack Obama, Ronald
Reagan, these are people who could intuit
what a given audience needed, and say that
idea that a majority of people were going
to turn out to be moved by and potentially
say different things to different groups.
Now, we often think that
if you're saying different
things to different groups that
that means you're a flip-flopper or
you're insincere, or you're being
cynical or something like that.
But I think that that's not really a
realistic critique in a polarized society.
In a polarized society where
people value different things,
they have incredibly diverse backgrounds.
We're going to have to be
comfortable with the fact
that people are going to have different
reasons for agreeing on things.
That people are going to come to major
issues like inequality or climate change
and potentially take the same side on
them, but for very different reasons.
And if we're not comfortable with that,
we're not going to get
political consensus.
[MUSIC]
I think that if we're going to resolve
all these tensions productively,
it's going to mean that we somehow
turn towards one another and saw
some humanity across political lines, like
maybe the existing strategies worked so
badly, that we wound up
saying you know what,
we're not going to do it that way,
the politics of division.
They're not working,
they're hurting the country as a whole.
And they're not really even helping my
side get a critical mass to pass anything.
And so I'm going to try a different way.
And then that's going to be us
turning towards each other and
seeing a common humanity
that we struggle to see now.
[MUSIC]